Donavan bots fight argument starts the
next point of the taxability eclair on
the commission betreff least our
industry the misguided suit sister or
patient abide nemo spare him before he
aspire ethnicity of invasion the student
is catch the eiffel fountain to the
blowin captains of oldest and Adri
history on all taught us no a system
design electron sharing assume the
material of middle east java DC option
mascara me to bring him certain see for
the sketch the eyes of honoring his film
boiling Fabricio Werdum idiots to
beginning only after ended you spa him
to button do spa a big indeed nominal
commission for communal ambien Kafka
thank you very much mr. president you
remembers as requested I let me make
this statement on behalf of the
Commission on the on the subject of the
EU steel sector first let me say a few
word on the trade defense measures for
steel over the three years period of
2013 16 the European steel industry
severe suffered truly severe severe
losses this was due to this trades
Padova's from Chinese overcapacity
but our policy respond was sweet and
comprehensive in March 2016 we issued a
communication laying out a number of
measures and compassing crucially trade
policy over the years 2014-2018 the EU
imposed and really unprecedented number
25 new measures covering steel products
the aim was to remove the injurious
effects of dumped and subsidized imports
and restored fur trading conditions
these measures significantly reduced
dumped and subsidized imports and
protected 216,000 jobs the EU took a
number of step to better protect the
steel industry in the trade defense
domain through import surveillance and
accelerated investigations the opening
of the investigations was bad based on
threat of injury where were justified
all the application of definite duties
returns clearly were warranted these
steps
significant impact still imports of
products covered by measures adopted in
the years 2014 2017 fell by more than 95
percent on average compared to the
volume of import before the measures
were imposed despite signs of recovery
for the steel sector in part due to the
inclusion of trade defense measures the
youthful industry continued to be
vulnerable and in 2018 the industry was
confronted with yet another important
challenge
it was the risk of injury stemming from
the u.s. section 2232 measures on steel
products and the risk of still of trade
diversion the Commissioner again reacted
swiftly to this challenge by the opening
of safeguards investigation early this
year the Commission and EU Member States
agreed to put in place definitive
safeguard measures considering the risk
of redirection into the u of substantial
amounts of imports from another
countries previously this destined to
the US market when imposing the definite
measures the Commission committed to
react reassessed the situation by july
2019 this was to ensure that their
functioning remained adopted to steel
market developments and to deal with
unforeseen circumstances the measures
consist of a tariff rate quota which the
factor limits imports from all countries
of origin to the average level of the
year 2115 2017 a 25% Duty is imposed
beyond this and this is a lower level
than the high 2018
these measures imposed until July 2021
allowed for impulse to continue at a non
injurious level and all of those they
were largely supported by member states
and industries the Commission continues
to monitor imports and will consider the
need for another review in the future in
case of change circumstances for example
brexit the Commission is also tackling
the route cases of over capacity by
actively participate participating in
the g20 Global Forum on steel access
positive in addition the European
partnership on clean steel and low
carbon steel making has been proposed
under horizon Europe this will pull
additional private and public research
and innovation investment to support the
development of breakthrough technologies
for the production of clean steel the
use also supporting the development of
clean steel technologies with the
Research Fund for coal and steel let me
also mention that under the next MFF MFF
will have horizon to europe and invest
you both new new sources for investment
and and research in the steel sector
through the strategic forum of important
on important projects for common
European interests the Commission is
identifying business critical strategic
value chains and define potential
actions and investments from industry
and public authorities this strategic
forum has priority priority prioritized
six key value strategic value chains
including the strategic value chain on
low co2 emission industry and the final
report has just been finalised last week
on the 6th of November
finally the Innovation Fund under the
ETS post 2020 when support will support
big demonstration projects employing
breakthrough low-carbon technologies and
it will cover up to 16% 60% 600 of the
relevant cost of the projects the yulik
legal framework is to is there to
protect also let me now move to the to
the labor market to protect workers in
case of industrial change and
disruptions several EU directive sets
requirements for informing and
consulting workers in cases cases of
restructuring it is the responsibility
of course of the Member States
authorities to ensure that the national
legislation transposing EU directives is
applied by the employers concerned while
the Commission has no power to interfere
in specific company decisions regarding
the restructuring plans it urges
companies to follow good press practices
on restructuring EU funding is also
available to support worker that we
mention of course the hue Social Fund
which is used to improve employment
opportunities from
education and long lifelong learning and
develop active inclusion policies and
the very important tool that we have is
European globalization and Jazmyn Fant
key instrument providing support to
workers made redundant as a result of
major structural changes the first step
to mobilize the EDF is for the Member
States concerned to submit an
application and the EDF regulation
provides for a minimum of 500
redundancies in an enterprise as a one
of eligibility criteria to trigger the
intervention in the case of course of
the small labor market or or in some
exceptional circumstances the rotation
from the this criterion is always
possible so as you can see the European
Commission has taken for a long time a
very clear stance to support the
competitiveness of the US steel sector
we issued a communication dedicated to
the EO steel sector the so called still
action plan we took steps to strengthen
steel defense against unfair trading
practices and let me concluding
underline that in our in our renewed
industrial policy strategy we stress
that robust industrial based in san
shelf is essential for Europe's economic
growth preservation of sustainable jobs
and EU competitiveness of the global
market thank you very much I'm looking
forward to your remarks finding Falco
missile ambien coughs conspires Preet
Phil I named my colleague Shalini grazie
Presidente buona sera commissural mi /
metadier in Graz er La Perla borodai
questi ani primera Veloso lager requests
ET quand la cuestión de la cheon l
industry severe Ushakov repay una
cuestión a enorme LP last row
constituted a lot cos tat otra dito the
multi fitori que karat original approach
un poco madeira dis involved respeto la
política industrial experince la grappa
butoh a questo junto in drama de da de
americana allah say o allah chain
generally que determine our
to reverse our sooner Oppo didn't or me
quantitative a system operates in
particular editor Kia let me surah dis
Alba Varden DVD wat and no so no
sufficient II know so no sufficient
aires retiro the most an inlet co2 Co
nalddo milliliter set Errol CDC percent
roll Nostra Mercato oj el treinta tree
percent Oh Dobie I mentor veneer in
impede endo quest a quest a derive a
idole ultra lotto monitor on dope i zk
non simply the most attention a la
tradición a manufactory era el caso del
italia shooter antonia una demostración
la ropa rinsing Alitalia Trotter beanie
la profe industria finding hug
colleagues Cellini s fault
Kalinda
grazie Presidente grazie a comas aria yo
sono stato newcomer Neel consider
commercial question a lab or okay safe
Otto in particular a perk until you are
de la cha sense a toast at oliver
importante era vato troppo tardy to
Tavia
a day Ankara troppo de boules sono molto
convent okay la revisión Adela miseries
al-baghdadi Avada Fatah
immediate Ament a subito abbiamo Jemaine
- Jemaine Seattle caso - co-anchor
quanto regard a lishchyna Shankara
multi-mode afar a multi-product en turn
on country Angola Sione Kevin Oh control
odd magenta macaque fr a con el proceso
de cambium into the lead astray de la
chayo a little noise a piano Cal
enormity vassula UT stato a particular
meant astringent a sous la cha
yo creed okay Val gal apena Rajan are a
non solo su phone euro paper Lara share
comma Fonda Perla transition industry
Oliver consent eerie alia Zaine di fara
Lauro invest Amenti ambient Ollie puri
no momento de grande difficult ah del
Satori de la cha Oh a a quest Oh scope
or even a real enormity vassula you
twisted garage filled ankle a calendar a
click calendar case turns on a frog -
Wow colleague in business car
to allow a question of colleague
business card